- Mein Name ist Bernd Schöllgen.
Ich bin Diplomingenieur,
hab allerdings den Beruf
des Anlagenmechanikers
– damals hieß er noch
Gas- und Wasserinstallateur –
auch selber gelernt und ausgeübt
und bin jetzt seit 1.6.2002 hier in der
Firma als Geschäftsführer tätig
und auch als Gesellschafter.
- Mein Name ist Patrick Hemme, und
ich bin Anlagenmechaniker, gelernt,
und hab die Ausbildung vor circa
anderthalb Jahren abgeschlossen.
- Ich bin der Andreas Mandt,
ich komm hier aus Alfter.
Ich mache jetzt seit zwei Jahren die
Ausbildung zum Anlagenmechaniker
im Bereich Heizung, Sanitär-
und Klimatechnik.
- Es ist sehr, sehr vielfältig.
Es ist abwechslungsreich:
Man hat mit Kunden zu tun,
man hat mit Kollegen zu tun,
man hat im Team zu tun, man ist auf der
Baustelle, man ist auch in der Werkstatt.
- Die Hauptthemen sind
natürlich Badsanierung,
Kesselsanierung und im
Bereich Kundendienst,
wo kleinere Reparaturen
gemacht werden
und Wartungen an Kesseln
durchgeführt werden.
- Als Anlagenmechaniker
ist man viel unterwegs.
Typische Tätigkeiten sind
zum Beispiel Wartungsarbeiten.
Anlagenmechaniker kontrollieren,
ob die Heizung richtig funktioniert.
Sie machen auch Reparaturen
– zum Beispiel in Badezimmern.
Sie bauen komplett neue Bäder ein
und installieren Fußbodenheizungen.
Mehr über den Beruf des
Anlagenmechanikers
erfahrt ihr im nächsten Teil.